hello and welcome to this video there's
a 725 10-game man one of those rapid
gains and we'll see what happens he I
want to do all of some of those longer
time control videos again not playing
that much blitz but varying a little bit
with what is going to be posted on the
channel okay let's see why why for you
is the opponent pre a huge raiding gap
you'll see on what opening we get a
strongly an old Indian yeah if he goes
'if I've now it doesn't now okay Quincy
7s also controlling e5 so very likely
you go play your five soonish yeah here
we go mm question is how to develop him
yeah I think there is no particular
point in delaying to Castle so I'm going
to castle we will likely Bishop e7 a.m.
and now Bishop e3 is looking very very
normal and there are also other options
of course I also do theatre rookie one
and we should f1 regrouping to support
the center now very likely black your
castle now blacks main point our main
idea here is to go a six and b5 gaining
space on the queenside yeah this
maneuver rookie one Bishop f 1 is 2 i'm
kind of tidy up White's position a
little bit increasing the support over
avi form and attacking the bishop the
way to a very safe square way it doesn't
hinder anybody else yeah as I said
normally black aims form some a six and
b5
yeah of course you can also go rook e8
or something like that to do something
similar what I did Ruby a bishop evade
these kind of ideas it's a very slow
kind of game what black probably doesn't
want to do is to capture on d4 this is
not really fitting well with the setup
taking on d4 is a more interesting idea
let's say if black hands fianchetto with
the bishop in the Kings Indian then it
is some he and this old Indian the
bishop one in seven is just far more
passive the bishop is on g7 so with the
bishop on g7 taking makes a lot more
sense yeah so we're going to see what
blackest coming up with the rook should
be eight yeah this is probably a
preparation for b5 I think Bishop e3
makes lots of sense this move is kind of
fitting into the position anyway and I'm
threatening now to take a five and take
a seven winning this a seven pawn with
the tempo so the rook is attacked and I
can retreat the bishop safely night g4s
of course possible this is a reply you
have to consider whenever you put the
bishop our treaty three okay so he goes
a six mm-hmm okay yeah I think t5 I
usually like to play it like that close
the center and um quite often black
replies with taking on d5 and playing be
five in this general kind of structure
however I doubt that this is good here
because on the queen is on the C file
with Luxio
on winning time okay so he just closes
the position now we have a typical
benoni structure let's see how to do
this b5 is very difficult to play for
black so I don't expect that to happen
in general I can do two things yeah I
can try to play on the kingside try to
expand death slowly I can try to play on
the queenside I think in this position
III intending before makes quite some
sense um there are some things that
point towards that one thing is that the
queen is on c7 in other cases on black
might be able to play 98 97 and prepare
be 5 so that lets say his preparation
for b5 this kind of not forcing oops
what is he doing there this is just a
pawn I think yeah I don't believe in
those sacrifices at all in this old
Indian check when only time and position
this is just dropping a porn I think
black this does not have enough
compensation here so let's see he
threatens rook takes be five and the
night at X eform this is some something
to take into account let's see how to
how to do it a couple of options even
the move before is interesting before
takes takes Queen takes be form rook a
form twin bit too and then rookie two
traps the Queen okay can take me five so
it doesn't trap the Queen what about be4
takes takes Queen takes and then some
other
move it really looks kind of bad like
this Queen could be could be trapped
don't see it however the mode look a
form Queen B to enter don't see it
Bishop save one you can play gypsy one
and the Queen goes way out no way this
is the truth there's the queen is trap
right before takes takes rook a four
things if that works it wins basically
it wins the game I almost almost
yeah I think I'm tripping the Queen down
no okay let's let's figure out if it's
really as good as it looks let's say
before mmm takes twice and Queen back to
the eighth this position I have the
ideal night a 72 66 I might even play
immediately that before strong let's
let's check and for final time that I'm
really trapping the Queen like before
text takes Queen takes relay for I will
need a queen bee too sorry only couldn't
be two possible Bishop see one twin be
one Bishop d3 and the queen is trapped
it can only sacrifice the Queen there
for 2 minor pieces which is not going to
be enough yes so before looks good him
let's do it the reason why I thought
about this for a while some is that I
also have just a clear advantage with
them ganman forcing moves like Bishop t2
or something like that just Bishop b2
and then a 3-2 a 4 is a clear pornhub
more space and what has a very strong
position close to winning but if you can
make be for work it's certainly it's
something that that should be played
only one lever I'm missing something
simple here what it looks like
it looks like a queen track what can you
do if it takes it twice and okay black
can also just move the Queen away yo
Mikey Queen should be six on that move
probably 92 is good yeah couple of
options it's not like by the Sun playing
with a couple of only moves yeah I'm
very skeptical towards any be five point
sacrifices in positions with c5 and e5
being played I just don't believe it
yeah black is trying to figure out if
there is still some way to continue this
game
you
when I don't really see a good move for
black
one issue is also if you if you look at
a 28 and I'm taking c5 after the D pond
recaptures d6 traps the bishop so this
is an additional issue sometimes and
where it's the Queen's supposed to go a
six maybe a six I can probably just go
92s route takes be 50 answered by a form
and 92 brings the night around yet to be
three and looks pretty awkward now we'll
see what is what is try is sorry for any
swishing sounds yet open up a bottle
need some water yeah not quite sure what
black still is up to as I went to a 6 mm
yeah now um I won them one one option
here is B take c5 of course him after
rook takes b5 I have a for winning the
exchange and in general the trade here
cannot be bad um I can also take you
five at then yeah this is actually quite
strong let's take it rook takes b5 I
have a for pinning this rook winning it
next move if we place night take c5 know
I was thinking Bishop c5 d take c5 and
night xe5 attending Knight to c6 wins
the second pawn and enters the position
on the light squares looks quite strong
yeah and pawn takes yeah not quite sure
I can always go like point xe5 can
always go night to d2
as roop Jake's b5 yep okay so yeah I'm
going to take on anything better I mean
can think of other moves and it looks
very straightforward now pawn takes
Knight 65 now and again Group B 5 is a 4
root b 5 a-4 2694 well that's a 426
counter-attacking the 90's night c
foursome it's not able to win material
yeah no moves running or black l
position after b5 just wasn't wasn't
playable I guess he M is basically
forced to UM play on some slowish
maneuvering game down okay but should be
five now I'm attacking d7 also twice so
where's the Queen going mm Queen d6 i
can go 97b should be 75 and this wins
even more material yeah the easiest is
to take it and play a five and now the
Queen in order to keep d7 protected
should go to see seven but then d 6 is
winning even more material
it was one of the bishops not much to do
about it
yeah like us trying to find something
probably but there is nothing nothing
left yeah he probably when we go to this
position here he probably has to stay um
yeah pass Sofia in some way maybe what
you can do as black gets too I can't
play the move okay I'm going to grab the
bishop yeah what you can quite often do
is play long term for f5 in a closed
position like that okay so f 5m let's
see if I can promote the points quickly
to force a resignation
yeah here in this kind of position black
and try like 90 a g6 97 and f4 f5 is the
long-term idea and much more likely to
succeed than any be five base play
yeah nice Korea of the opponent from
efore to e7 in five moves it's very nice
and he's going to promote like it's no
way black resign to to stop that okay
let's so let's have a look back at the
game black play to the old Indian here
with this d6c 697 I think if black ops
for this and it's a playable opening
it's not particularly better anything
you should probably not play Quincy
seven now and the reason is that is not
a necessary move you don't need this to
prepare you five and you can go be five
straight away for example this is a kind
of typical line where the Queen stays on
c7 this gives you more flexibility for
example one major line here is this
where black is much more or much happier
with the Queen being here than on c7
where it's stuck on an open sea fowl so
the queen is good on the eight there's
no reason to move it early on as it
doesn't really serve a clear purpose and
it looks like it prepare c5 but you can
play it immediately so still nothing bad
happened oh this is normal and rook be
eight hmm yeah if you want to go for a
6b five four you don't need that move
strictly speaking there should be three
and now a six yeah auntie White has a
choice he can play on okay and you can
do a couple of things let let me start
with some options of course I can go
what I'm go with D file what I actually
play it is the kind of book that I
usually prefer in such a position you
can also um just play
a little waiting move like this and
allow like to play be five then trying
to take and now exploit this this is
what I what I meant yeah the c-4 file
can be a problem here with the Queen
being on c7 by the way and this is of
course also possible when again move
like this the queen is a little bit
uncomfortable another option here for
white is to prevent be five but simply
going a four that's possible a drawback
of this booth can be that black plays a
five and in this type of position it's a
little bit awkward for white because the
deep horn whenever it moves and
capturing is entirely wrong in Hartford
whenever it moves let's say ahead to d5
we see that it's giving away a very good
square and be force also potentially a
piece for and the place for a black
piece like a night for example this is
still not the end of the world because
why it still has more space I think
given the choice I would still rather be
right here than black in this position
but black definitely has gained a little
something compared to some other
positions okay well I went d5 this is
just making sure that white has the
advantage in space and it asked black
about the pawn structure the main that
point of jihad is that it's now
difficult for black to play b5 if he
goes b5 I just take take and something
like this is very awkward this is a week
pawn and there are threats already this
is just a very untimely way of opening
the position b5 is not playable if black
wants to play b5 he would need to take
here first but here again we have this
situation that we had a multiple
multiple times already in this short
analysis that the queen is misplaced and
the whole situation can also be
looked at with this move being inserted
I will go back and now again black can
go be five however if I do something
like this it's not much of a difference
why there's also a bit better here
because the Queen loses more time and
note that this is a fairly passive
position black it's not really able to
do much an interesting idea here for
wide is to play like this a 3 night a 2
night before 96 um in the actual game
black played c5 this is of course a
possible option that's not something
that um is yeah losing for black or
anything but we we have to be clear here
this is a an old baloney or check benoni
with see 585 being played where black is
a tempo down with 65 he has played the
useless move Queen c7 and the fairly
useless move rupee 8th and a 6 usually
in the check been only black isn't doing
much on the queenside and prepares an f5
based counter play something like 98 g69
to g7 and potentially later f5 here I
went a 3 and at something that this is
what black probably should go for yes
something like 98 and medulla yeah i'm
going to play before the question is do
have doing this now or after some prep
if i go for it now what you have to
check is stuff like this as the night is
unprotected but the problem is so i
cannot take him maybe this is actually
possible those points look quite
dangerous but it's pointless anyway
because white can play like this and
black is in very bad shape or 92 million
yeah ultimately this just opens up on
the flank wear widest better and so
probably after be formed black is not
going to take or anything but try to
hold the position
b6 and then I probably play 92 would be
one and yeah this is a very long
maneuvering battle I had an idea that
white sometimes can go for us to
activate this bishop the bishop is not
doing that much at the moment and it has
two ways of activating this the snake
like maneuver here try to potentially
sink into c6 on let's get rid of couple
of arrows to go g3 and Bishop h3 which
is also activating this piece I think
white is is better and I think it's also
something substantial it's not just a
little advantage that that white
sometimes has why just has substantially
more space and the black counterplay
that is well existent in the Czech
benoni but slow he is even slow down
further black having lost a little bit
of time in the game black played this v5
move and I think this is just not
looking at all I'm grabbing the pawn and
black doesn't have enough compensation
yeah now before not a necessary move as
I said I can also play the should be to
let's say and play a 4 which is also
quite strong okay be far before I
haven't looked like yeah look detractor
that same and okay so one thing is this
when I thought I'm trapping the Queen
well yeah okay the engine agrees that
I'm basically trapping the Queen a this
was the line and but what i can do is
this is true you can of course go for
the sacrifice and here why does better
it's a queen up for Luke enter and night
but it's probably not something where
black has to resign like immediately the
engine actually wants to do this yeah
this is probably more convincing
okay this place was played and now our
computer likes now to be to deform and
tending 96 yeah I understand but I think
the capture is also pretty strong so
this is this and 95 white is no two
pawns up and he still has this knight c6
ideas yeah and TI 84 was winning even
more material yeah I know what is the
rook up and not going to promote the
points for quick decision yeah I hope
you liked the rapid game here um it's
some something that I haven't done for a
while but i will try to do more often in
general um I try now to post roughly 30
to 40 minutes or video per day if I
manage it it's a little bit tricky at
the moment but I try to and it is this
mixed it will be some blitz some rapid
some instructional content so yeah I
look forward to a little bit more over
yeah I would say that the channel should
be a little bit less predictable yeah
with all the blitz games should be some
other content day as well hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching